he's a Georgetown University professor
whose latest book is what the truth
sounds like RFK James Baldwin and our
unfinished conversation about race in
America Michael Eric Dyson
[Applause]
[Music]
how you doing professor hey you still
have you still profess right no
professor what what it what is it like
for the kids to have such a star in the
room are they starstruck oh man you know
when you come to class know they're
there you know what they do say my
mother told me to come take your class
or my grandma's a fan of yours I said
but not you that's good I get a little
of that too right so your book is so
fascinating because and you write so
beautifully it reads like a novel always
you're unbelievable but what attracted
you to this particular moment because I
was not aware of this this this meeting
that that sort of starts your book off
about Robert F Kennedy whose passing was
50 years ago this week that's right yeah
and he had a meeting in 1963 he wanted
to meet the black leaders who he wanted
to hear really what who blacks listen to
that's right it was Harry Belafonte
right right it was who Leena o Leena
Horne
Geraint Bal James Baldwin Lorraine
Hansberry and he admit and I love how
you start that I didn't know about that
meeting that's that's my that's the work
of an author right to bring the story
that very few people know about if they
do it's episodic read a couple pages
here a paragraph there but I was curious
about I said boy I want to read a book
about it I couldn't find one I said let
me write it myself and this meeting was
extraordinary because he'd met he being
Bobby Kennedy who was then the United
States Attorney General his brother was
the president and he said look I see a
crisis brewing in urban America there's
a lot of rage going on here people are
attracted to the extremist groups and
they're turning away from Martin Luther
King jr. or Whitney Young head of the
Urban League or Roy Wilkins who's head
of the n-double a-c-p
but I don't want to talk to the
politicians to Adam Clayton Powell or
King as a leader I want to talk to as
you said to black people who have the
ear of black America he met with Baldwin
at a breakfast meeting out at Hickory
Hill his place out in Virginia Baldwin's
plane was late they didn't talk for
about a half an hour he says look the
next day I'm gonna be in you know New
York don't you bring a few of your
friends if you can gather them up and
come on over to the house and when
you're James Baldwin your friends are
Harry Belafonte Lena Horne and Lorraine
Hansberry really wanted to Bobby Kennedy
wanted to know what's the dilly
I mean what's what's going on with black
America what it right and who is he
asked yeah look contrasting what we have
now that's a huge huge benefit and
advantage in this country because he was
actually curious and when he got to the
meeting let's be honest though he's a
politician so he wants them to be
grateful be grateful for what we've done
me and my brother but his brother Robert
a John Kennedy was an extraordinary
politician but he was playing both ends
against the middle he was putting on the
bench people like Harold Cox who was a
right-wing bigot in his spirit and
allegedly a liberal but he's calling
people horrible names from the bench
he's also you know telling the governor
of Georgia when he plays a well time
called to Martin for King Jr's imprison
er there that look you let him out of
jail he let King out of jail and then a
few days later there was a an election
and all the black people who could vote
voted for him but he told that governor
we will not use federal forces to
support integration when I come into
office then he selling black people hey
I'm gonna support the civil rights
movement so he was caught in between
that and Bobby Kennedy thought Oh Bobby
Kennedy got an earful he got an earful
at the end of all he thought it was
gonna be gratitude they said right not
really
we're not here for that and they gave
him for lack of a better word Hill and
they really gave it to him hard
a young men was their name Robert Smith
Jerome Smith I'm sorry and he was a
corps Congress of racial equality he was
one of their Freedom Riders and next to
John Lewis nobody was beaten more than
this man and he cut to the chase I'm not
here for your BS I'm tired of all this
talk you're doing this party pitter
patter stop it Bobby Kennedy was shocked
and then when James Baldwin said well
wouldn't you go asking this young mr.
Smith trying to Ratchet it up he said
would you go to your took to order to
fight for your country he said never
Bobby Kennedy was upset from there it
got worse Lena Horne said don't turn to
us respectable Negroes keep talking to
that man cuz that's who you need to
listen to and for three hours they lit
him up and gave him a new perspective he
got pissed he SiC the FBI on them he got
the dossiers of many of these people who
were there including Clarence Jones who
was the lawyer for both Baldwin and
Martin Luther King jr. but then he
calmed down and then he said if I were
black
I'd be pissed too I'd be full of rage -
and then he started telling his brother
start speaking about race as a moral
issue not just a political one and then
he in his own life began to change and
had a lot more compassion and insight
about the nature of black suffering he
thought that the black people there that
night were - emphasizing on emphatically
personal storytelling rather than public
policy but what he discovered is they
understood the public policy without
dealing with the anti blackness that was
afoot in the land would never do enough
so it was a tremendous I want I I wonder
today if policy even matters to black or
white I mean I see the things that Trump
is doing he isn't on yet at the White
House right today he was talking about
maybe lifting the ban on the federal
illegalities of marijuana right right so
he he pardons I forget her name but
Alice Mary Jane yes you know and people
we're gonna watch TV and they're gonna
see grateful black folks Thank You
president right right this anecdotal way
I wouldn't be surprised if he goes up in
the polls oh sure I mean he's a master
manipulator shrewd and but the problem
is this you know and as he challenged
the football players you know tell me
the people that you think need to be
part in an outright well that individual
approach doesn't deal with system
doesn't do what structure there are too
many people you don't know their names
because they're nameless and faceless to
you there are a bunch of people that you
continue to to consign to the dustbin of
history and you don't think about him
instead of pardoning some dead black
people how about some of living ones who
are here now and well he did well then
with Alex
yeah but you can't do it individually on
a case-by-case basis the system itself
is producing been eruptions and
inequality but again we live in a
country where not everyone is a
professor right
I understand everything you just said
was what yeah well he let this beautiful
black lady go Ballmer didn't do that
well that's true isn't jail all that I
mean there's a lot of low-hanging fruit
yeah that he's just widely enough right
that could make you popular legalizing
pot he could do that tomorrow he do it
just to piss off Jeff Sessions right of
course and he'd get a lot black and why
I'd be a day if he pardon my brother
who's been in prison for 29 years I'd
say hey that was a good thing right but
here's the point if if what we do is get
seduced by the belief that it's an
individual thing and not a system
systematic they agree with the problem
is is that you pick and choose you
cherry-pick I like this person if you
happen to know Kanye West if you happen
to know Kim Kardashian right if you
happen to know somebody famous who can
advocate for you the problem is those
who have nobody to speak for them that's
why you got to talk of for him I got to
speak up for him in fact I'm part of the
heart rate ought to do the right thing
ought to do it time and time again
[Applause]
I thought it was very eye-opening in
your book what you wrote about Bernie
Sanders
you know and Trump right that you know
most people think of those two as
opposites yeah and you see a lot more of
a connection yeah they're both older
white men who are cantankerous well and
one is attracted - of course -
rhetorical fluency the other one can
barely speak but that aside right I mean
one is a butthurt brain-dead bigot the
other one is an insightful critic of
things but they're both older white guys
who were slow to understand what race
was about in America and after Trump was
elected even Bernie Sanders said you
know we got to do something about this
identity politics it's alright to deal
with women it's all ready to deal with
african-americans and Latinos but let's
get back to the politics from where the
point is that that white is an identity
- and what Bernie Sanders didn't
understand if you subsumed race on the
class in other words you think class is
the big deal race is something that's a
consequence of that you're missing out
on the fact that even poor white people
sometimes are bigoted against poor black
people it's not like class overcomes
those differences they want the Latinos
out they don't want black people in
their pipefitter unions or becoming
police people environment so the point
is that class has to always be
intersected with race and gender and
sexuality and Bernie Sanders was slow to
that so I saw them as mirror images of
the same kind of figure I'm not saying
that Bernie Sanders is Donald Trump in
terms of ideology but certainly in terms
of approach and ignorance about race but
at least he's trying to educate himself
in a way that Donald Trump is allergic
to well we could all educate ourselves
better with your
Michael Eric Dyson
[Applause]